alors ici je me trouve près du métro des
invalides et finalement l'ambiance ici
ressemble à ses débuts de cette
manifestation c'est à dire au festivent
ensoleillé avec beaucoup de musique art
puisque la manifestation ici est en
train de se terminer
les manifestants se dispersent les
forces de l'ordre ont sommé le public
ici donc 2 à quitter les lieux
et d'ailleurs je suis avec linda bigot
qui est une figure du gilet jaune qui a
tenu à ce qu'est un maximum de gilet
jaune qui viennent ici aujourd'hui pour
montrer leur soutien au personnel
soignant finalement que m'avait dit tout
à l'heure quand on parlait il fallait
dépasser les applaudissements sur les
balcons à 20h pour soutenir les
personnels soignants mais venir leur
montrer vraiment le soutien de toute la
population française aujourd'hui
effectivement pendant le confinement
toute la population française en
majorité applaudit tous les soirs à 20h
le personnel soignant qui étaient au
front de véritables héros à soigner
l'ensemble de la population en mettant
en jeu leur famille leur vie avec très
peu de moyens et donc c'était je pense
effectivement légitime d'être là
aujourd'hui de leur montrer notre
connaissance de les soutenir au travers
de leurs revendications
je tiens à rappeler que nous gilet jaune
avant l'année dernière au mois de mai
organisé une manifestation en soutien
aux personnels soignants
nous avons été lors de nos
manifestations précurseur d' alerte en
lançant c'est à l'air que ce soit pour
le personnel soignant
que ce soit pour l'éducation nationale
contre la loi bancaire que ce soit pour
les retraites pour les blessés des
violences policières que nous avons
subies donc aujourd'hui un an plus tard
le constat est là justement que qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
pourraient éventuellement accusé
aujourd'hui les gilet jaune de vouloir
se greffer un mouvement un peu plus
large pour c'est pour essayer de grandir
un peu leur rend pas du tout alors
personnellement j'ai été en contact avec
certains membres de l'organisation de
cet appel aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas souhaité déclaré parce
que c'était leur événement mais ils ont
accepté qu'on soit là en soutien alors
là vous venez de revenir sur toutes les
fois où vous avez effectivement appelé
les gens à se mobiliser depuis le 17
novembre 2018 il faut le rappeler quand
même vous avez des noms c'est
effectivement ce que me considérer comme
une casse sociale
ici en france est-ce que vous avez
l'impression quelque part les jets les
jaunes ont été précurseurs ont été en
avance sur une colère nationale dans le
pays mais complètement complètement dès
que monsieur macron est arrivé au
pouvoir nous avons tout de suite
constaté qu' il nous mentait dès le
départ qu'ils n'avaient qui n'allait pas
tenir ses promesses
il a dit qu'il ne toucherait pas aux
retraites eh ben un an plus tard on voit
que c'est pas le cas
le code du travail pareil le service
public est déjà à l'agonie avant qu'il
vienne au pouvoir il a asphyxié encore
plus alors quoi de plus légitime pour la
population que de sortir tous ensemble
main dans la main essoré nos
institutions parce qu'on en a besoin
une dernière question une d'habibou tout
à l'heure m'avait dit avant ce direct
que finalement vous étiez un peu triste
de la manière dont
ces manifestations avaient un peu
dégénéré à un moment et qu'ils aient
finalement confié le message de départ
de cette mobilisation
et bien ce qui est triste c'est que à
chaque fois depuis quelques mois
peu importe le mouvement contestataire
qui se passe dans la rue on se confronte
ajustement de la violence policière
un maintien de l'ordre qui n'est pas du
maintien de l'ordre puisque le droit de
manifester est complètement aliénés
moi ce que je comprends pas ok d'accord
la police doit maintenir l'ordre
mais pourquoi venir intervenir pendant
le déroulement d'une manifestation
et on peut le constater que peu importe
ce soit chez les gilet jaune que ce soit
peu importe la manifestation organisée
on l'a encore vu samedi
alors on est toujours là braqués les
caméras vers soi disant ceci ou cela
mais moi je braque la caméra vers les
forces de l'ordre et les donneurs
d'ordre une manifestation peut bien se
passer
à partir du moment où les forces de
l'ordre tiennent leurs distances d'avoir
répondu à nos questions d'amico nous
entends décemment table comme le rouleau
je me disais tout à l'heure la situation
a dégénéré
effectivement plusieurs fois pendant
cette manifestation qui avait bien
commencé qui se termine pour le moment
dans le calme en tout cas là où je me
trouve près du métro des invalides où on
avait effectivement plusieurs personnes
sortir de ce pré carré qui était au
monde était menacé depuis maintenant
plusieurs heures finalement le soleil
est revenu après un petit passage
pluvieux le soleil revenu la musique
aussi est là pour l'instant l'ambiance
est plutôt bonne il n'y a plus
d'affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre et les manifestants
en tout cas ceux qui restent ici sur
cette place